[Musique]
c'est une histoire méconnue aux états
unis l'aventurier et colonisateur
français lesueur de cadillac a établi un
poste ici en 1701 et l'église sainte
anne est toujours là pour en témoigner
la famille mounier leurs familles un
moulin sont des familles fondatrices de
la ville de détroit
on ne parle plus français depuis belle
lurette dans la paroisse mais john
cooper
passionné d'histoire né dans l'ohio
voisins s'emploient à faire revivre cet
héritage il est aussi passionné de
politique et il adore le président tron
lui il se tait la loppsi 2 et comme vous
faites déjà constatée moi je suis aussi
de nature un outsider
il n'aime pas nécessairement le style du
président mais il est totalement
d'accord avec l'ensemble des ses
politiques ses positions sur réduction d
impôt sur la stimulation de l'emploi de
faire face à la chine
quant à savoir si le président tram sera
trouvée coupable ou non d'avoir violé la
loi dans ses échanges avec le président
ukrainien
tout cela ne les brûlent pas si on le
démontrait vous pourriez changer d'idée
vis-à-vis monsieur tram n'aura non parce
que on nous a raconté tant de mensonges
jusqu'ici
à une heure de route de là vers le sud
au delà des villes plus démocrates et
des banlieues plus partagé le michigan
conservateurs se porte très bien
[Musique]
austin devait rentrer chez lui après une
journée de travail pour l'entreprise
d'asphaltage familiale à 20 ans ce jeune
homme est un farouche partisan des
libertés individuelles et de l'égalité
du citoyen pour lui toutes les solutions
économiques et sociales en dépendent ses
convictions sont simples et claires il
va voter pour donald trump leur
prochaine quoique cette histoire
ukrainienne ébranle légèrement ses
convictions sauf si le président a
vraiment tenté de marchander avec
l'ukraine pour nuire à son adversaire
joe biden oui il y a matière à
d'institutions dit il
il ajoute l'économie va si bien il
serait difficile de voter contre lui et
la région a été durement frappé par la
crise économique de 2007 2008 rappelle
cet analyste politique pour l'instant
dit elle les électeurs ne changent pas
d'avis même avec la procédure de
destitution en cours christine cros
[Musique]
les investissements privés ont repris
dans la ville de l'automobile de grands
travaux de rénovation sont en cours et
la population se croisent les doigts
chaîne si vous êtes un de ses électeurs
du michigan qui peuvent changer
d'allégeance d'une élection à l'autre
il a déjà voté pour obama
en 2007 il aurait préféré bernie sanders
comme candidat démocrate
il a donc voté pour cet employé d'une
agence de marketing mais bien l'image
d'un entrepreneur créatif et déterminé
de trompe mais l'opportuniste se
transformer en démon dit il il ne votera
pas pour lui la prochaine fois il faut
acheter la position de trump demeure
fragile ici dit-elle destitution ou pas
ce match reprend ainsi les tarifs sur
l'acier ont fait mal aux manufacturiers
de la région
la marge d'erreur est mince
à la dernière élection dans notre coin
par remporter l'état du michigan par à
peine dix mille voix soit 0,3 pour cent
des suffrages
et c'est ici qu'il avait tenu son
dernier rassemblement de campagne son
futur adversaire démocrate pourra donc
pas intérêt à s'en rappeler en 2020